hi everybody I'm Andrew bloom garden
thank you for coming I'm gonna be
talking to
about what I've spent the last year
working on with many many people the ant
region project at New Relic we've
redesigned the infrastructure New Relic
runs on to support scaled lead building
and operating many regions so in this
talk I'm presenting it as an open
retrospective talking both about the
technical and the organizational
challenges of the project and what we
learned think of this as a case study in
the way a medium-sized company deals
with the challenges of operating at
scale again both technically and
organizationally so most of you have
probably heard of New Relic but and so
you know some of you or maybe even
customers of ours but let me give you
perspective of what we do from the
perspective of an engineer at the
company we're an observability company
they build software that our customers
used to analyze how their software
actually works in the wild that means
that our customers send us a ton of data
that we process in store and then we
present back to them in the form of
alerts curated UI's and ad hoc queries
all for a variety of different products
so we have mobile agents browser agents
agents that can be installed in JVMs you
know we you know customers send us data
from all of that and then we present it
back to them so they can see how their
software is actually working and last
year is part of our partnership with IBM
we agreed to build out a region in
Europe in IBM's data centers in
Frankfurt in order to be able to let
European customers keep their data in
the EU up until this point all data
would come to the US whether or not the
company was actually in the US and note
that this isn't the same as some kind of
multi region projects where you're just
building it out for redundancy we needed
data isolations result as a result of
this so we signed this deal and then
engineering found out about it and this
was a pretty scary proposition despite
our fairly well run organizations so let
me explain why so I started at New Relic
eight years ago and we had just one app
it was great was the UI and the data
collection tier it was all-in-one it was
a rails monolith did everything it's
great for local development and then
shortly after I started one of our
engineers without the collection tier
into the aptly named collector it was
written in Java and it was a couple of
orders of magnitude faster and it was
more efficient than the initial rails
implementation which probably isn't that
surprising and if we had stopped at that
point this would have been sometime in
2010 and we you know said okay it's time
to build a European region technically
this would have been totally fine we
could have you know tweaked a couple
code bases
some hardware in Europe you know we were
running at such a small scale this no
big deal but we didn't instead
in those eight years since that time
we've introduced new products and
features and we've scaled enormous Li
and to handle that growth we've had to
continuously re our contect our software
so today we're handling around 30
gigabits per second of traffic inbound
processing around 15 million care
messages per second writing 600 million
events per minute to disk this our key
value pairs that our customers send us
like for about a transaction an
application or a sample of a host host
CPU usage that kind of thing we have
around 50 engineering teams and a
hundreds of engineers on those teams and
this is what our architecture looks like
today so like most service-oriented
architectures this reflects both actual
technical requirements we've had them
you know spin up all these products we
have to handle all this data there's no
way this could have worked on our
original architecture and that also
reflects organizational structure and
architecture is at the point where a
singl easily understandable diagram
can't faithfully represent it in all its
detail and there's no way that our
original you know one or two have
architecture would have scaled as far so
we did make the right choice but we
never really considered that we'd ever
have to run in more than one region it
was always a potential future that never
seemed to arrive was like you know okay
you know maybe next year we'll build a
European region but we're not gonna make
decisions now that is going to make that
easier we're just gonna keep doing what
we've been doing so the business set
times now we're gonna build a new region
we knew this was going to be a really
painful exercise for us so we then you
know asked okay are you ever gonna want
to do this again and they said yeah
probably so we changed the project said
okay we're gonna change this we're gonna
build the enth region we want to make
that focus on building tools for
building regions so that the next time
rather than every team at the company
having to make changes to their software
ideally one small team of engineers can
be the ones to turn up a new region and
you know we were you know cute about
this we call this project backpack as we
mostly Americans we're going to get on a
trip to Europe so I said that we ran in
one region but that's actually a little
bit of a lie we did have experience
building your regions because every year
we do a disaster recovery exercise where
we prove to ourselves and to our
customers more importantly that
now in the event of something terrible
happening we can rebuild the entire New
Relic sack in a new environment some
were geographically distant because the
assumption is it's probably like you
know some kind of terrible thing
happening where our data centers are and
we knew that this was really painful for
us and you know we did prove that in the
event of a real emergency we could drop
everything and recover but the exercise
just took a lot of effort across the
entire engineering organization so when
we started the EU region project we knew
that's what we have to look into why was
this so painful so in the 8 years I've
been at New Relic we've had to solve a
variety of problems we've had to figure
out how to deploy many services we
support a polyglot environment we have
services written in Ruby and Java as I
mentioned we have services written an
elixir and go probably a few other
languages I'm not even thinking of teams
can make that decision on their own we
have service discovery you gotta have it
for that many services you need to have
some kind of secret management system
and you need some kind of container
orchestration and now we're gonna say
tack on multiple regions cool we got
this except we didn't so earlier this
year I read a blog post from will Larsen
who's worked at Digg uber and now stripe
and he wrote about the concept of
migrations and he wrote that migrations
are the only mechanism to effectively
manage technical debt is your company
and code gross if you don't get
effective at software and system
vibrations you'll end up languishing in
technical debt and the truth is we've
solved all these problems but we didn't
really migrate the old stuff away so it
seemed like we were really successful we
had container orchestration we had
secret management we had all these
different things but the reason they
seemed successful was just an artifact
of our fast growth new software or very
recently new so a software would be
written using the new patterns tooling
etc but the older software just usually
didn't come along for the ride maybe in
the event of a major incident we would
say oh that software hasn't really been
touched in three years maybe we should
make it you know run into container that
kind of thing would happen occasionally
but it was never a systematic effort and
the fact is that a variety of vintages
might be nice in your wine cellar but
it's not what you want for managing
large-scale software systems so here the
you know rough vintages of New Relic at
least relevant to this project dating
back to 2010 we had systems that were
Ruby and Java applications deployed via
Capistrano to hosts that were managed to
note
let me say Capistrano - hard coded list
of hosts meant deployed systems that
were managed via years of crufty puppet
code that we didn't manage well around
2013 is which is when our service
oriented architecture push really kicked
off we were extremely early adopters of
docker because we knew that the cap and
puppet approach wasn't going to scale
for us and you know that was pretty
painful at the time docker wasn't super
stable these days it is but and there
also wasn't really an orchestration tool
so we built a Capistrano style tool to
deploy docker container is called
Centurion around the same time we built
an in-house service discovery system
cervesa
but anything written in the past couple
of years doesn't really use this anymore
because we kind of abandon it dating
back to 2016
secret management we need a better
solution gonna deploy vault and finally
we you know daughter sell stuff together
when we're gonna deploy a mace those
cluster our container fabric project and
some much better build and deploy tools
on top of that what we call Grand
Central and so you take all of this
together and that means that a disaster
recovery effort has to account for every
single one of these and every single one
of the systems that are in these
different buckets have to be accounted
for so what we'd seen in our dr
exercises was there was just a ton of
busy work and toil involved in
supporting all these flavors a ton of
time was spent copy pasting
configuration tweaking it for the new
environment finding out that you made a
mistake repeating it over and over and
maybe finally it'll work and one good
example of how bad this got was that we
weren't comfortable merging a
long-running branch to add the dr
environment to our puppet configuration
just because it got so large and complex
our Centurion story was pretty similar
Centurion has managed via rake files so
it's Ruby you can do anything but mostly
it looked like this hard-coded let's
suppose some environment variables so dr
as a copy-paste and tweak our cervesa
system for service discovery which was
much much better this is code to access
our feature flag system this wouldn't
have to change at all but as I mentioned
we didn't really use this as much
anymore and so there were services that
had just huge hard-coded blocks of
service discovery let me zoom in on one
this is how one service asked accessed
our agent databases by short ID in the
disaster recovery environment so if you
imagine that we want to support you know
many regions this kind of thing is not
gonna fly anymore and unfortunately
while our mesas platform was awesome
and made deploying containers a lot
easier the management around it didn't
really try to solve this problem either
it had blocks of configuration in Y amel
that you couldn't really share except
you if you were gonna try to do some Y
Amal sharing tricks which you know
typical led to incidents when you
realized you did it wrong
if you copy/paste that you knew that 4dr
make some tweaks maybe it's gonna work
so we knew that we need to figure out
what are the changes that we need to
make to support ones one team or a small
number of teams building this new region
what we really needed here were just
strong interfaces both between different
parts of the technical system as well as
between teams in the infrastructure and
you know just to you know reiterate the
conference like strange loop probably
don't need two interfaces are really
valuable because they separate the
contract from the implementation so let
me give an example of what putting an
interface in a system can do this is a
real process at New Relic for getting
database credentials a team would say ok
I have a new service I want to talk to
this database or this service is now
going to talk to this existing database
they would file a ticket they would wait
for the database team to get to the
ticket to add the credentials say to
last pass and share them or to the
database and then share them via
LastPass then the team would receive
them they'd add them to the service
configuration and then they deployed the
service and you know this works ok for
ongoing operations but if you wanted to
say repeat this entire pattern for every
single service database combination we
have in production for a new region it's
gonna be very very painful so even if
you know what you do is you say well
we're just gonna put a programmatic
interface around this there's you know
you say this service needs access to
this database there's a black box and
then you deploy even if on the inside of
that it's still manual work the database
team is adding credentials manually
sharing the mint or putting them in the
right place so the service can read them
the database team is then free to say ok
cool we can you know spend some time
automating this get out of the business
of manually generating credentials and
the value here is that encapsulation
lets small teams act independently if we
had said ok we need to change our
human-driven process and have every team
in the company have to change to
correspond that's a big project but if
we'd set up the right interface only the
database engineering team needs to care
about it
so what we needed to do in this project
was figure out what are those high
leverage interfaces those things that we
can get every team of the company to
cooperate on so that we can unlock this
and future value and for the company so
I'm gonna go through a few things that
we settled on and you know a bunch of
work but it's been really valuable first
service discovery so as I mentioned we
had our survey system was a homegrown
system that you know read some
configuration and did dynamic service
discovery worked pretty well had some
problems also tons of hard code search
hard coded service discovery and more of
our recent services had service
discovery via environment variables
where they'd find some URL or some other
host name or something but oftentimes
those values are actually hard-coded as
well in a configuration file we didn't
have a solution for credential
management and I don't mean where you
put the credentials with how the
credentials get there in the first place
and also we had no way to do static
analysis so I'm gonna take a brief
digression and talk about why static
analysis is really useful when you're
thinking about the problem of building
out any region or you know just thinking
about the architecture of a system in
general so if I'm you know in charge of
deploying in your region and I'm gonna
be no either write software to deploy
services or you know click buttons to
deploy services and I need to deploy
service Alice it would sure be nice to
know that service Alice actually depends
on service Bob before I deploy it and
then suddenly it's broken maybe I even
don't even find out about this until a
couple days later because the service
thinks it's totally fine it's health
check isn't actually checking its
dependency this is real life this
happens if you had static analysis you
could say oh well before I started
employ service Alice I must deploy
service Bob so I'll do that and then I
deploy service Alice and everything's
great and this is the key flaw that our
services system had survey said was just
run time service discovery it could be
embedded in many layers deep in a
library that's folding by library that's
called in by library you know could be
across repos there's no good way for us
to tell oh this service actually talks
to this other one it could be very
buried very deep on the other hand we
did have something that you know if you
squint it at it maybe could get up to
give us that information environment
variables services have some
configuration that say you know if Alice
says I need a you know a URL for where
Bob is
if we had the right kind of inspection
technology we can look at this and say
Oh Alice actually depends on Bob
because if Alice needs this URL they
have to um now the reality was that we
had a bunch of different formats for
expressing this data services would take
either URLs with a path or without or a
hostname but if we can you know put a
little layer of abstraction in place
here and say okay you the service are
going to actually just declare that you
need to know where Bob is this discovery
path syntax and then will replace it at
deploy time or run time with the actual
value of where Bob is then we can solve
this problem we can figure out Oh what
services depend on each other and this
also helps us solve our credential
management problem because you know the
classic example is databases a service
needs access to a database there's
probably that's hopefully authenticated
and our services typically took you know
some subset of these five values for how
to talk to a database but those can also
be passed in a new URL so we can extend
our discovery path syntax to say okay
this means an authenticated dependency
if I see an @ sign that means I want
credentials along it with it in the URL
this is the service discovery as a
dependency injection services declare
the dependencies locations are injected
via environment variable on a standard
format credentials can be part of those
URLs and most importantly static
analysis is possible and the key here is
that again we're not necessarily using
this data at the start but we're
building the system so that we can
improve operations iteratively in the
future we can pull this data out and
start to do interesting things the next
thing is containers everywhere so we'd
known from this 2013 when we first
started using docker that containers
most importantly are an interface
between teams and the machines that they
run on back in the in the bad old days
if I wanted to play a new ruby service I
needed to go tell our puppet folks or
write a puppet PR that would say what
kind of but Ruby version is going to use
what libraries it's going to use make
sure that the OS version is compatible
and this you know didn't work with it
well well at all for us so docker solved
this problem it was great but we had the
Centurion overhead of having to you know
manually specify lists of hosts and you
know in the meantime technology had
progressed a ton we hadn't made so so we
had kubernetes and we had a mesas
project in flight so we were able to say
that all of our stateful services
actually moved to our container fabric
cluster and just be orchestrated and
this will remove a ton of busy work both
for us operations as well as for the
future EU operations and you know we
knew the power of containers and but we
didn't really generally speaking run our
stateful services in them but you know
we could see where things were going
soon enough kokuboro Nettie's is going
to be able to solve this problem for us
we're gonna deploy it but we don't want
to bite that off as part of this project
but what we can do is make sure that
everything is going to be in a container
so that when that day comes it's a much
easier left and we do actually have
experience running stateful services and
containers our largest Cassandra cluster
had been running in docker since 2015
project we called dock Sandra we had
multi tenant relational databases in
docker since last year and my colleagues
actually gave a talk at four Kona live
about it earlier this year and that also
allowed us to do one more really
valuable thing which is to standardize
on core OS not CentOS so core OS is a
Linux distribution that has one job and
that job is to run containers and it has
solves two related problems for us first
the configuration service is just so
much reduced compared to other Linux
distributions it doesn't even have a
package manager to the point where if
you want to do anything useful you
probably want to put it in container
which is very convenient because that's
what we want to see and also it has a
first boot configuration system ignition
it's pretty well matched at a lot of
configuration that core OS actually
supports which means that we can safely
abandon our unloved Popat installation
that means we don't have to produce a PR
that we're never going to merge you know
we can just say we're done with puppet
and you know that's no shame on puppet
that's a shame on our management of it
one other nice thing about ignition is
that it has you know ignition itself is
a semi human readable and questionably
human writable JSON format but it has a
nice camel layer on top of it that is
human readable and writable and it's
also the transpiler from that yam bowl
to the Jason is available as a go
library so we can integrate it into our
machine provisioning process and
actually make assertions about what's
going to happen so at New Relic we want
to run the New Relic infrastructure
agent on all of our hosts we can put
that in the ammo files and then we can
write unit tests to say just by the way
make sure that every single machine is
going to get this agent on it finally
the last thing that we needed to do was
ensure that we were using terraform for
the new environment a lot of
infrastructure is just fiddly
estimation okay this s3 bucket needs
this flag this s3 bucket needs that flag
and that's something that we kind of
managed over time but a lot of our older
buckets are honestly our more crucial
buckets were not managed to be a
terraform or maybe they were managed via
cloud formation stack that we can't
touch
so using terraform allows us to just
make that repeatable and the terraform
project and community provide a lot of
off-the-shelf providers that make
different cloud api's accessible from
terraform but you can also develop your
own it's pretty easy and we found that
biting the bullet and developing
terraform providers to close these gaps
that we encountered paid off repeatedly
so to give you an example IBM provides a
terraform provider for their
infrastructure as a service and that
works pretty well but we have a
different notion of machine lifecycle
that we want to impose on that we use
bare metal machines with IBM they have a
notion of a monthly billing cycle we
want to be able to provision in destroy
machines between months okay let's write
a provider we're gonna make that happen
it's not too bad and then we can just
continuously reuse that from terraform
now you may all be thinking this is kind
of sounding like a bit of a second
system level of project you know you
started out with okay we need to run in
EU region and we've got service
discovery containers terraform you know
for a huge system this may sound pretty
risky and you're probably right this was
really risky and we did try to de-risk
it a little bit by choosing problems not
to tackle we didn't try to you know get
all our safe whole systems running in
containers that were orchestrated by
kubernetes as part of this project and
you know another example is in our US
region we run Hardware f5 load balancers
we can't give that to IBM to run for us
but what we can do is say well we're
running on core OS we can run Santos
containers and that can run virtual f5
VMs ok cool let's get this to work and
that means that we don't have to deal
with load balancing as part of this
project and it's important to remember
that at the end of the day if we had
gone ahead with this and not made the
system better we could have ended up
with just twice the ongoing operational
load and more importantly just the same
amount of time to build out a new region
and if you know you repeat this a few
more times we'd likely down to drive the
company down on your endless operational
toil or be forced to turn down business
opportunities by not building new
regions at all so you know we had to
just find the Goldilocks balance choose
the right work
you know there were things that we could
have chosen not to do but we tried to
find you know the right level of changes
to accomplish our goal so with all of
that said we had an execution plan for
this project this is you know purely
like design this is what we want to see
now you know here's where the rubber
hits the road how do we actually get
this done what we hoped was we would do
discovery of the IBM environment of our
own systems figure out what we needed to
do and that's basically where all the
stuff I just talked about came from then
we would document all of that in
broadcast it was time to do the work
teams would do this work in parallel
they would do some repeated test build
outs find problems repeat and finally
stand up a for-real environment and
leave it running then we test that and
then we ship it to our customers and the
hope here was that you know we could
time box this work
keep team's involvement relatively
constrained to just a couple of
milestones containerization and one
targeting testing the new region and it
but in between those two we wanted to
ensure that teams could and could and
would do other things for example
earlier this year we ship distributed
tracing support which required a whole
lot of teams to do a whole lot of work
and if we had said okay you know all of
that can't happen because backpack we
would have been in trouble this project
would not have happened that said that's
great and all but I wouldn't be standing
up here in front of you if the project
had gone perfectly or you know maybe I
would be but honestly I think that that
would be pretty boring because none of
the things we did technically are all
that unusual maybe the service discovery
thing is a little bit unusual but you
know what's more interesting to me is
that we made some change the changes at
some scale so I'm going to go over some
lessons that we learned along the way
and some each once each one up with a
set of things that we'd start stop and
continue in future large-scale projects
and I hope that these are all lessons
that can be relevant to you as you
consider large-scale projects of your
own so first quick ramp ups how do you
prioritize the work the backpack project
was predicated on having support from
the business because we needed basically
every team at the company to do work for
us so we needed that work to get on
their roadmap so let's talk about how
Road mapping works in New Relic
first it's important to note that every
engineering team at New Relic is
autonomous that means that they have
their own roadmaps which is set by the
team and their product manager to meet
both the team's own goals as well as to
meet the broader requirements of the
business those broader requirements come
from a group known as the product
council which every quarter or so
produces a list of the top five
high-priority
projects in the company in order of
priority and teams are supposed to
contribute to those projects if they
can't and some of the projects might be
something that only a single team can do
and what that means is that other teams
just need to make sure that that team is
not blocked they can get their job done
and for large projects like backpack it
means that the work for the project
preempts the rest of the teams roadmap
now this project actually does work but
there's a catch what happens if a
project needs resources to move forward
but the product Council for whatever
reason hasn't prioritized the project
yet that's what happened with that pack
there was a month or so of delay where
you know we thought we were ready to go
we needed teams to do work clock was
ticking and it wasn't prioritized and
then suddenly all of a sudden we were
prioritized almost all teams were
knocking at our door and like this
roller coaster at California Adventure
in Los Angeles where I grew up this
roller coaster has a fast start if you
don't know what's coming you're gonna
smack your head and that's kind of what
happened to us in retrospect this sink
swing from no support to near total
support just wasn't good for the project
we had had to transition from operating
relatively independently you know doing
all this discovery work doing some
build-out in the environment to having
every team at the company knocking on
our door trying to figure out what the
hell they had to do and the discovery
worked there was well organized you know
there was a process for having meetings
but even still it left the backpack
engineering team scrambling with our
sudden success in getting attention you
know we just weren't ready we didn't
have full documentation of what we were
looking for service discovery tooling
wasn't ready court ruling wasn't ready
and most importantly we just didn't have
an easily digestible philosophy of what
we were actually asking people to do how
to think about the problem space we were
in if engineers had understand how we
were thinking about this how we were
thinking about the problem better they
could have made better decisions along
the way there would have been less
thrash and we didn't have that clearly
articulated we'd articulated it in
pieces along the way but not in one
place where people would go to
understand so in the future we're gonna
start preparing for what happens when a
project actually gets that high priority
we're gonna produce a project philosophy
document and we're going to keep it
updated if things change and we're gonna
continue prioritizing important work
across the company because that is
useful relatedly
the biggest problem we ran into was that
the project was rightly seen as
continually moving goal posts for teams
so up front we did specify ok there's
going to be this
in work there's going to be moving to
container fabric there's gonna be
service discovery being environment
variables but we the project leads also
knew that there was going to be some
smaller work to come for example our
initial instructions asked teams to make
the service discovery work via URLs in
this very specified format and we knew
that the tooling would come along to
make it so you could swap that out for
the discovery path syntax and get the
tooling to automatically inject that
format for you but we didn't really
mention that didn't mention that was
coming we knew that teams needed to do
the work and we didn't want to you know
say oh you can't can't get going on that
until we're ready with this other thing
um and we didn't really communicate
pieces like that at all during the
entire project or at least in the early
phases instead we just talked about and
tracked the big-ticket items up until a
small item came up and this was
intentional for a couple of reasons
first each team has a hero rule that
passes around typically via the on-call
rotation and their job is you know both
to be on-call as well to handle small
requests from other teams so we thought
that the smaller stuff to come could be
handled by the hero and also we didn't
want to exhaustively work list work that
couldn't be done yet especially since we
didn't know precisely what that work was
going to be in retrospect this was a
mistake most especially and not
communicating that there was going to be
just follow-up work at all even if we
didn't know the full extent of it and
also the fact that the teams here are
rotated meant that there were cases were
you know we would say hey hero you need
to do this thing for us and the hero
would be like wait what I haven't
actually been doing any of the EU
supporting work at all that's a lot of
context wishing that's required so
that's one kind of moving goalposts and
that would have been bad enough but
there was another kind we ran three
tests build-outs one at the beginning of
december one in January and one in
February and our goal in planning this
was to iteratively improve the
infrastructure side of the build outs
for example to realize that our initial
network architecture was wrong or to
figure out how to provision machines
better and had the opportunity to tear
the entire thing down and build it up
again which is an opportunity you
usually don't get in production so that
actually happened but the build outs
were also just repeated integration
exercises finding out exactly what
didn't work together yet you know wasn't
suffering through all of those problems
so the reality of a build out was that
we'd been heavily encouraging teams to
do work in the u.s. to prove out the EU
work because we can we made it possible
there but there were things that they
couldn't find there out were wrong until
they actually deployed it in the
then you know because teams weren't
finishing their work at the same time it
didn't quite line up with the build-out
schedule for many teams their schedule
would look like they do the work in the
u.s. they'd realize they couldn't test
it in the EU they'd move on to something
else and then the backpack team would
try to deploy their software and realize
something didn't work and suddenly be
knocking on the team's door saying hey
hey hey this thing's broken
and at that point they very well may be
blocking the effort entirely and you
know this was made worse by our decision
to have the backpack team attempt to
deploy each team's software is a way of
ensuring unwanted shortcuts weren't
being made but you know and that worked
when teams and when services didn't have
problems but if there were problems this
was a lot of thrash and sometimes this
even happened a few times for the same
team which really wasn't a pleasant
experience for anyone involved and even
though in our minds here the goalpost
was always works in the EU we didn't
really make that clear and working in
the U is just a broad definition the
team thought that they were done and
then they suddenly weren't and if other
things were changing around them maybe
they really were done and they couldn't
get think and then suddenly things
started breaking so in retrospect we
should have used as some kind of steel
thread effort now trying to involve a
smaller number of teams earlier on to
validate all the steps that went into
building a new region it probably would
have eased stress but on the other hand
it could have lengthened the overall
wall clock time of the project because
we could have spent time with a small
number of teams and then realized oh we
kind of missed some things or this team
over here that has a ton of work didn't
get started until three months into the
project and the overall schedule is
going to be delayed that said there's
probably a better balance to strike than
what we did so know in the future we're
gonna start with some kind of steel
thread effort we're gonna be more honest
and transparent stop hiding hidden work
even if only by acknowledging that
unknown huge future work exists but we
are going to avoid waterfall planning
for a project like this for a large
software system there's no way we could
have specified everything up front so we
do need to still need to be agile we
need to be able to change our minds
midway through the project or realize
that some other things need to happen
next and I know this is going to shock
everyone in the room communication is
hard so new relic has a strong culture
of internal blogging is the means of
broadcasting ideas and posting updates
on project projects and the idea here is
that this makes communication easier
we're telling everybody what's going on
and by we I mean everyone in the company
is telling everyone what's going on
so the trouble with an internal blogging
culture is there's just a lot to read
and discuss everyone's constantly
writing new posts and it's virtually
impossible to know what you as an
individual should be keeping up on so
that problem of too much to go too much
going on to keep up on was a problem
writ large not just in writing even when
we started having town hall events to
broadcast updates to the entire product
organization we still weren't reaching
everyone blog posts they don't get read
town hall events people don't show up
it's too early in the morning it's too
late we have offices in Portland in
Barcelona
that's a nine hour time difference we
deployed a checklist app to try to help
with the problem you know checking each
step with a project for each service but
if a check that new check box appears
because we've added something to the
project that requires someone to notice
a checkbox appearing or to read the blog
post that they didn't read we did have
internal linting infrastructure but that
was out of band and not widely used and
had some problems which meant that it
was mostly ignored teams that did use it
found it somewhat useful but this could
have been a lot better what we did
realize later in the project would have
helped was centralized documentation of
what we wanted we'd avoided this
initially because what we we worried
that teams would see some kind of
centralized documentation see it
changing and then get frustrated that
things were changing out from under them
so we thought that some kind of blog
post strain would be better but we were
wrong what we should have had is a
centralized documentation with some kind
of huge user readable change log not get
commit saying these are the things that
have changed at this point in the
project so that a team that's coming
into the project later can catch up
someone who went on vacation can catch
up without having to catch up on you
know four weeks of blog posts so in the
future got to have that potentialized
documentation having better linting
would have helped a ton but we're gonna
continue to blog internally it's really
useful for engineers to know what's
actually going on at the company and
have a more flat organizational
structure as a result of that and you
know we're gonna continue to communicate
it using as many channels as possible
because we know that one just does just
one doesn't work next local maximums one
consequence of our incomplete
standardization was that teams were just
heavily incentivized to make the system
better locally so what I mean by that is
let's take a thought exercise imagine
that you're on a team three years ago a
new relic and you managed say 20
services it's all a part of one system
and you want some things
that the platform doesn't provide you
you want chain to place from service to
service or from stage into production
you want some kind of shared
configuration and you want service
discovery and so you build all these
things and for three years you get the
benefit of it before the company
provides them to you as part of standard
that's tooling and now someone comes
along and says ok as part of this
project we need you to start using the
standardized tooling because we need you
to be on our mesas platform and that has
only one door in it's not gonna be great
you're gonna have some kind of
transition pain but the promise is that
after you're on standardized tool and
you're just gonna be in much better
shape but the reality is that you're not
really gonna be there's gonna be some
aspect of the standardized tooling
that's almost certainly worse than what
you built for yourself because it's
solving a more brought a more general
problem not what you actually intended
to solve and this isn't a good way to
make friends is if you know they're a
bunch of teams that have done this work
and you're asking them to abandon their
work all simultaneously you're really
not going to be able to you know give
them an option if you need them to do
the work for the broader project they're
gonna be resentful I don't have a good
answer here but at least we can have
more empathy for teams stuck in this
situation and if we communicated well in
advance that this was coming
perhaps our central tooling team could
have you know close some of these gaps
earlier now but also you know I just
kind of made some assumptions about how
people will react and we also have to
stop doing that some teams may have
great standardized tooling but may be
sick of the maintaining it and just
having someone else to do that job for
them maybe that make them excited to
move on to somebody else's problem but
and we are gonna continue making
standardized tooling better it's what
allow this project to work in this
person in the first place which gets us
on to my next point
leaning on what you have probably the
best decision we made in the project
planning was to piggyback on work that
was already in progress
we had our container fabric team
building our maces platform we had our
buildin deploy stool team building our
grand central build and deploy system
and we had to did our database
engineering team building our
containerized database platform in the
addition to the obvious benefit of
skating where the puck is going not
trying to change the direction of the
puck this has the benefit of effectively
expanding a project team to all of those
teams as well there what it was a bit
rocky at first we needed to make sure
that everybody understood where we were
going but once everybody was on the same
page these broader project teams were
able to contribute to the overall
direction of the project do some
key features that allowed the project to
work at all that said similar to the
experience of the backpack team getting
prioritized by the product council the
team's running migrations already in
progress suddenly saw huge optics and
adoption thanks to backpack this is good
they're getting more people to use their
stuff that's one of their goals but it's
also quite stressful because suddenly
you have 30 teams knocking on your door
saying oh this thing is broken on the
other hand one of our design goals was
to put the work for infrastructure
improvements on a small number of teams
rather than spreading it across the
entire company
so in some sense that was the right
decision so in the future we're going to
make clear which priorities are highest
for infrastructure teams and we're going
to continue to look for high leverage
work a small number of teams can do last
but very much not least the importance
of a pilot phase so I mentioned that our
original plan was you're gonna do
discovery we were gonna fan out test it
ourselves and then ship it to customers
but we realized that there was just no
way that we could assure our customers
or ourselves that this system was going
to be stable when we ship it if we
shipped it in this way so we didn't
delay GA significantly opting instead to
run a pilot phase for a very limited
number of customers and that allowed our
teams to be on the hook for reliability
without the same consequences when
things inevitably went wrong we're
running on a new cloud we're running
with some new infrastructure things are
going to go wrong we don't want that to
be a very public incident that knocks
out our entire European region this was
absolutely the right decision
just having wall clock time with real
customers that expect and accept
problems allowed us to experience both
bugs is on our side which happened and
incidents in the underlying cloud which
also happened we can never completely
avoid problems but at least we can
practice our response and now we're in a
much better position so here I honestly
don't know how we ever thought it was
going to be okay to build out an entire
region using new technology and just
ship it immediately it's kind of magical
thinking so to sum up where are we now
first it's most important to note that
this worked we have a European region if
you're interested in it contact your
salespeople or contact me you know we
can hook you up and we're also seeing
dividends across the board in our
disaster recovery work we saw an order
of magnitude fewer engineering hours
going to the project that's huge and
it's only going to continue to improve
as there you know further changes we
can make to make the process better we
have less busy work involved in service
operations and we've laid the groundwork
for even or more improvements there too
we have 95 percent of our services
running in our container fabric this is
great and there's a bit of a meta
benefit the more we expand our
operations in stay on the bleeding edge
of software and infrastructure practices
the better able we are to serve our
customers doing the same so is heavy
users of New Relic ourselves we can run
into the rough edges hopefully before
our customers do and then make the
project product better in advance of
them running into those problems and we
learned a lot learned about running
large-scale projects and that's going to
keep to help keep helping us as we grow
delivering features as a small team is
really fun and it's valuable but when
you can successfully coordinator large
number of teams to do a huge project
like this you can do really amazing
things so in the future we're gonna
continue a little bit of magical
thinking and trying some bold things so
thank you to you know free all of you
for coming and also for all the hundreds
of people who worked on this project and
also we're hiring thank you
[Applause]